buongiorno a tutti
ebbene sì sono un criminologo non so se
si è fatto più paura io a voi io voi voi
a me ma oggi non vi parlerò di sangue
vi parlerò di città del futuro e
criminologia e sicurezza
sicuramente viviamo in città che sono
intelligenti o stanno diventando più
intelligenti ma in città intelligenti
noi continuiamo ad avere paura e la
criminalità continua ad esserci e le
forze di polizia lavorano male le
risorse sono sempre più scarse
si può fare qualcosa di più che cosa
possiamo fare in queste città
intelligenti ecco sono convinto questa è
l'idea che oggi vi voglio trasferire che
le città intelligenti hanno degli
anticorpi contro la criminalità la smart
city ha degli anticorpi o li deve
sviluppare come svilupparli il tema di
cui vi voglio parlare
me ne occupa da alcuni anni me ne occupo
nel mio gruppo di ricerca circa dal 2012
2013 e più di recente me ne occupo di
una startup dell'università di trento
che abbiamo costruito dove facciamo
ricerca sulla sicurezza delle città ma
facciamo un passo indietro e cerchiamo
insieme di rispondere ad una domanda la
criminalità nelle città si può prevedere
sembra minority report ma vi assicuro
che c'è della scienza nella risposta a
questa domanda se cerchiamo una risposta
porto non è dato recente venezia
qualcuno di voi forse l'avrà letto 15 la
notte tra il 15 e il 16 qui sembra fare
proprio il criminologo tra il 15 e il 16
novembre erano le 3 45 di notte
un criminale un ladro con la refurtiva
scappa da un albergo c'è qualcuno che lo
rincorre trova una volante ad
acciuffarlo quella volante era lì perché
un software aveva detto alla questura di
venezia che tra le 3 e le 4 in
quell'area si sarebbe verificato un
reato non è minority report questo
software si chiama hicks files hicks
scherzo hicks lo si chiama se andate a
vederlo battuta si chiama hicks la
serietà adesso è quel software è un
software di polizia predittiva che è
stato realizzato dalla questura di
napoli con l'università federico ii ed è
in testa in alcune questure italiane ma
non è un'idea del 2018
e un'idea che nasce negli stati uniti
nel 2010 dove l'università della
california dei ricercatori hanno a lungo
lavorato con il dipartimento di polizia
di los angeles e hanno costruito un
software che si chiama brad paul che
oggi è in ben 60 distretti di polizia
delle polizie americani negli stati
uniti vedete qui alle mie spalle che i
quadratini sono predizioni nello spazio
e nel tempo questi software usano la
criminalità passata
i dati di criminalità passata per
prevedere la concentrazione nel futuro
della criminalità nello spazio e nel
tempo dove verranno con buona
probabilità i reati nel futuro stiamo
parlando di reati urbani grati che hanno
una dimensione di solito patrimoniale al
massimo di reati violenti urbani
a los angeles con l'utilizzo di questo
software la criminalità di anno in anno
dal 2018
ad oggi si è ridotta in alcuni anni del
20 del 30 per cento
l'obiettivo di predko questo nome del
software è cercare di capire dove vanno
i reati
lo fa con algoritmi di predizione non è
un nome bruttissimo statistiche
matematica quindi per andare a capire
dove avverranno i reati in futuro
basandosi sul passato perché il passato
insegna il futuro è la stessa cosa che
fa il software della questura di napoli
della questura di venezia con una
piccola differenza li si guarda la
serialità del reato siccome i reati
spesso ai criminali sono seriali sono
professionali fanno più reati io riesco
a prevedere il prossimo reato di una
serie sulle caratteristiche della serie
stessa quindi la criminalità può predire
la criminalità futura il dato di
criminalità nella città poi farci
imparare dove avverrà la criminalità ma
è abbastanza oggi le città sono più
intelligenti di solo di un solo dato
sulla criminalità oggi le città hanno i
big data
se sono intelligenti quindi l'idea è
come utilizzare questi big data e a
questo abbiamo cominciato a lavorare
nell'università con un progetto che
abbiamo realizzato qui abbastanza unico
direi al mondo che abbiamo realizzato
qui dove forse criminalità non ce ne è
tanta anche se non bisognerebbe dire
perché trentini non lo sono convinti con
la questura di trento dal 2013 al 2015 e
con l'università noi come coordinatori
con la fondazione bruno kessler e
soprattutto ci tengo a sottolineare il
comune perché questo è un elemento nuovo
il comune e le amministrazioni due
domande per capire l'idea che gli voglio
trasferire la prima è questa per
prevedere la criminalità nelle città
serve davvero solo il dato di polizia
per capire che cosa succederà per capire
dove andrà la criminalità serve solo
questo dato
abbiamo solo questo dato è la seconda ma
siamo sicuri che costruire sicurezza
nella città vuol dire solo evitare reati
futuri vuol dire solo partire in modo
più efficiente
il territorio da parte delle forze di
polizia
sicurezza vuol dire solo questo
sicurezza vuol dire anche sentirsi
sicuri sicurezza vuol dire stare bene e
vivere la città e spesso vivere bene la
città e non volerla vivere può essere
non dipendente dalla quantità oggettiva
di criminalità ma crei struire sicurezza
a costruire sicurezza urbana vuol dire
lavorare anche con questi temi voli su
questi temi vuol dire lavorare con i
cittadini
vuol dire lavorare con con le
amministrazioni ed è questo che abbiamo
fatto e per farlo
siamo andati ad immaginare una città
futura che vuole prevenire la
criminalità e quella città futura è una
città fatta di dati è una città fatta di
sensori e una città che a sensori nel
territorio che ha gangli che può
prendere informazioni e li può prendere
anche dai propri cittadini comunicando
con i propri cittadini in via costante e
questa comunicazione porterà ad ottenere
tanti dati di che tipo dimentichiamoci
per un attimo i dati di polizia alle mie
spalle
vedete una carrellata di possibili dati
che oggi esistono in città che non sono
neanche tanto intelligenti perché
esistono città più intelligenti di
questa che vi sto per mostrare e che ci
stiamo tratteggiando in questo momento
nella mente dati sul traffico
i dati sul traffico parlano della
vivibilità delle città ma parlano anche
di dove andiamo e dei posti che lasciamo
sguarniti quindi hanno a che fare con
sicurezza e hanno a che fare con
criminalità dati meteo se piove di
domenica io sto a casa e se sto a casa è
molto improbabile che vengono a rubare
mentre io ci sono
se invece non piove e vado via al mare o
al lago è probabile che si rubi uno
stupido esempio scusate per farvi capire
quanto le condizioni climatiche
influenzano la criminalità e la
sicurezza uso dei trasporti pubblici una
m piena è un luogo dove avvengono
tantissimi borseggi è un dato di fatto
più siamo stretti come in un mercato più
ci sono un'opportunità criminali ma una
m piena alle dieci di sera in centro
città
vuol dire che quella città probabilmente
sicura
perché il centro città è vissuto perché
i cittadini stanno uscendo perché ci
credono e quindi vivono la città e
quindi il dato della metropolitana piena
e può essere in alcuni casi anche un
dato di sicurezza di percezione di
sicurezza dipende da come lo uso dati
nei parcheggi traffico
vi ricordate non lo facciamo tutti
entrano una città che non conosciamo
andiamo nel parcheggio più vicino con i
posti a disposizione quel dato il comune
ce l'ha ma un parcheggio pieno
all'aperto e un parcheggio dove
avvengono possono venire con più
probabilità furti di oggetti dalle auto
perché perché il ladro si abbassa e si
nasconde tra le automobili ed entra
nelle auto quando invece ci sono poche
macchine ci viene da dire chi ruberà in
quel momento che non si ruba sulle auto
quindi il dato quel dato un dato che ci
può servire dati sulle utenze dei
cittadini di luce gas e acqua vogliono
semplicemente dire quanto viviamo le
nostre case e se lasciamo disabitate o
se ci sono interi quartieri e vi
assicuro che si può vedere solo con quel
dato lì che sono spenti e se coi
portieri sono spenti sono disorganizzati
sono quartieri dove c'è disagio sociale
dove c'è disorganizzazione e quindi dove
c'è probabilmente in sicurezza
ecco chi quel dato mi sta parlando di
un'altra cosa dati di telefonia mobile
ciò quel telefono ovviamente non so il
gbl la geolocalizzazione le
geolocalizzazione accesa
se l'avessi so dove sono se ce l'abbiamo
tutti siamo in questo teatro
quando camminiamo quel dato parla dei
nostri movimenti e sapete che il dato
dei telefonini e quello che predice
meglio della concentrazione e quelli
delle persone che usano i telefonini la
criminalità in città dopo la criminalità
stessa immaginatevi la forza di quel
dato lì e se un quartiere della città in
centro mentre tutti gli altri sono
vissuti quel quartiere non a telefonini
accesi e perché le persone probabilmente
potrebbero avere paura non stanno
visitando quella parte del centro quindi
quel dato lì che oggi le telefoniche
vendono hanno limitato lasciamo fare da
parte questa cosa è un dato importante
che può essere usato
e tutte le telecamere che mettiamo
sapete che le telecamere oggi possono
lanciare allarmi contano quante persone
passano quante macchine passano al guano
algoritmi intelligenti per identificare
caratteristiche fenomeni e quelle
caratteristiche identificate possono
finire in delle banche dati
la telecamera quindi digitale ha un
potere informativo che va oltre all'uso
che di solito noi pensiamo possa avere
e poi i dati di polizia locale le nostre
molte l'amministrazione della polizia
superare la polizia municipale non le
forze di polizia
quel dato lì è un dato sulla gestione
del territorio e ci sono città
intelligenti da noi milano per esempio
che hanno un sacco di informazioni di
polizia locale ei social media
oggi mi hanno rubato in casa
oddio mi sento insicuro in questa città
terribile sono appena arrivato e non so
dove andare sembra tutto buio anche i
dati sulle illuminazione sono importanti
e ci sono delle città intelligenti
il dato del social è un dato di persone
che comunicano sicurezza oggettiva o
sicurezza soggettiva
bisogna solo saperlo guardare e poi
applicazioni nelle mani dei cittadini
perché non fare un atto in cui segnalare
ce ne sono segnalare reati segnalare in
sicurezza segnalare paura segnalare
disordine che ci dà fastidio e ricevere
segnalazioni dalle nostre comunicazioni
sulla sicurezza delle nostre
amministrazioni perché oggi queste
tecnologie consentono quella
comunicazione che non fa sentire solo il
cittadino ma quei dati sono dati che noi
possiamo utilizzare e poi la
collocazione degli obiettivi sensibili
una scuola un bancomat un ufficio
postale
e così via i facilitatori casi e che
sono rimaste incustodite che possano
diventare un luogo di spaccio permette
dei luoghi di protezione come può essere
una caserma
questi influenzano la criminalità
rispetto a dove si trovano
oppure la mancanza di criminali
le percezioni di sicurezza e poi tutti i
dati che tutti i comuni hanno purtroppo
sempre meno open anche se dovrebbero
essere open sui dati informazioni
sociali demografiche molto fini l'ho
fatto probabilmente una testa così ma
pensate di avere tutti questi dati a
portata di mano di prenderli per scopi e
di utilizzarli per scopi diversi da
quelli per cui sono stati creati e
costruiti
lo scopo per noi oggi è prevenire la
criminalità e far sentire le città più
sicure e cittadini più sicuri
allora prendete seguitemi e immaginate
di essere in una grande sala una inglese
la chiamerebbero perché si usano questi
termini non quando si fa contro le tesi
criminologia security control room una
stanza di controllo sulla sicurezza da
quella stanza io sono in connessione con
i miei poliziotti come i poliziotti
municipali con i miei cittadini e in
quella stanza c'è un software e quel
software noi l'abbiamo già creato non vi
sto parlando di una cosa lontanissima si
chiama vigilia non l'abbiamo fatto con
questa startup e non so perché gli
assomiglia non è importante un software
che fa che cosa che prende quei dati che
magari li mescola con i dati della
questura e fa predizioni molto più
accurate su dove avverrà la
concentrazione di criminalità nello
spazio e nel tempo e le fa più accurate
per che unirà anche dati di carattere
social di carattere sociale tutti i dati
che vi ho fatto vedere e quindi saranno
più raffinate e queste previsioni a
trento anni fa le abbiamo fatte e
funzionavano molto è meglio nella
semplice pulizia predittiva ma poi fa
una cosa in più
la risposta a quella seconda domanda che
vi dico che vi ho posto che ci siamo
opposti fa sicurezza urbana questo e non
è che gli abbiamo dato predittiva fa
sentire vicino ai cittadini fa capire il
perché di disordine in sicurezza
criminalità fa capire come intervenire
perché oggi c'è molta pancia nella
gestione della sicurezza urbana e non
solo nella gestione dell'asi con della
criminalità mentre serve un po più di
testa un po più di raziocinio capire
vuol dire intervenire e non solo quando
noi interveniamo immaginate di un
sindaco può mettere più illuminazioni
può mettere le telecamere può fare più
bella la città ha tantissime opzioni ma
poi non sa se queste opzioni funzionano
se quei dati continuano a monitorare noi
sappiamo se gli interventi funzionano
questa è l'idea di una città
intelligente che anticorpi che si
protegge che è vicina ai cittadini e da
un'amministrazione che con i dati sempre
tutelano la privacy
questo non l'ho detto ma è più che ovvio
arriva a prevenire ea contrastare e
anche a combattere la criminalità
facendo sentire la sicurezza a tutti più
vicina è un'idea che sembra lontana ma
vi assicuro che un'idea vicina con
quella start up ma stiamo già costruendo
in una città molto grande italiana e
speriamo di poterlo fare presto in tante
altre città vi ringrazio per
l'attenzione